bonjour à tous nouvelle édition spéciale
élections régionales sur france 3 la
gauche est donc parvenu à conserver la
bourgogne franche comté avec à sa tête
et marie-guite dufay l'une des trois
femmes future présidente des nouvelles
grandes régions nous la retrouverons en
direct de besançon au conseil régional
dans un instant nos invités et côté
bourgogne michel neugnot est avec nous
bonjour je vous avais joué un rôle
important dans cette campagne du parti
socialiste nous y reviendrons vous êtes
également réélu conseiller régional et
puis nous attendons une minute à l'autre
le député-maire les républicains de
beaune en côte d'or alain suguenot avec
nous également des réactions depuis
besançon avec catherine m séries et vos
invités bonjour catherine bonjour
bonjour en effet trois invités sur le
plateau donc socialiste les républicains
également un additif front national
merci catherine
à tout à l'heure et puis nous entendons
également la voie d'un député ps
frondeurs christian paul nous dira
depuis paris ce qu'il attend du
gouvernement après ce scrutin et puis
nous allons donc l'arrivée sur ce
plateau en direct d'alain suguenot
bonjour pour les républicains
nous analyserons également ce scrutin
avec vous dans un instant d'abord les
résultats de ce deuxième tour à suspense
donc la liste ps prg est arrivé en tête
avec 34 7% des suffrages devant celles
est rude et de françois sauvadet avec
32,9 le front national obtient 32,4 avec
une participation en hausse de plus de
10 points par rapport au premier tour la
répartition par siège maintenant du
futur conseil régional sans élus au
total 51 pour la gauche 25 pour la
droite
24 pour le front national sur les 51
sièges à gauche 47 élus ps un prg un
divers gauche 1 udf union d écologie un
cap 21
les 25 à droite 17 pour les républicains
6 et 10 et 2 divers droit 57e représente
la départements de bourgogne et 43
conseillers
pour la franche-comté marie-guite dufay
était jusqu alors la seule femme
présidente d'un conseil régional celui
précisément de la franche comté
élu le 4 janvier première présidente de
la nouvelle entité franche-comté et
bourgogne
le résultat du deuxième tour s'annonce
serré et c'est effectivement ce qui
s'est passé aline levinsky et david
martin l'ont suivi lors des différentes
étapes de la soirée un banc bourguignon
pour traiter la victoire d'une
socialiste franc comtoise
ainsi va la vie dans la nouvelle grande
région ayant conscience que y'a du
boulot mais bon voilà ça ça viendra on a
besoin de savourer maintenant le fait
que ensemble on a fait du bon boulot
pour que cette région grande région bah
comment son histoire avec la gauche
ils ont dû faire preuve de patience les
colistiers de militants et sympathisants
socialistes
c'est peu avant minuit que la nouvelle
présidente est enfin arrivé à leur fête
improvisée après un véritable marathon
médiatique
j'ai pas tout à fait ma comédie des
journalistes qui eux aussi ont dû
patienter
marie-guite dufay a attendu d'être sûr
de sa victoire pour s'exprimer
arrivé une heure plus tard que l'horaire
annoncé en préfecture elle est assaillie
de questions delpero je pense
qu'effectivement dans notre famille de
gauche nous avions beaucoup
d'abstentionnistes qui se sont réveillés
donc cela c'est très bien mais s'il
s'était abstenu c'est parce qu'ils
doutent aussi il ya un profond doute par
rapport à rapport à la gauche
aujourd'hui j'en ai conscience
il faut absolument beaucoup de questions
de toute part analysé cette victoire en
tirer des leçons
c'est un nouveau chapitre qui s'ouvre
mais tout reste à écrire
et avant de retrouver marie-guite dufay
en direct de besançon faisant mieux
connaissance avec els 66 ans élevé
depuis 40 ans en franche-comté 25 ans de
vie politique à besançon son pouvoir et
ses responsabilités seront donc accru
par cette fusion des régions
théo sous mango anne etienne la nouvelle
présidente entre dans la lumière
un peu oui
il est 7h30 à dijon marie-guite dufay
arrive dans les studios de france bleu
inconnu en bourgogne il ya encore
quelques mois elle est devenue hier soir
la première présidente de la nouvelle
grande région c'est fort quoi c'est fort
aussi dans les monts battu donc c'est le
résultat d'une belle bataille et puis en
même temps je sens le poids de la
responsabilité
bonjour à tous avaient jusqu'à présent
la présidente de franche comté le
puissant président de la bourgogne
franche comté réunima une surprise de
plus dans le parcours politique de
marie-guite dufay adjointe au maire de
besançon dès 1989 puis conseillère
régionale en 2004 elle prend la
présidence de la franche comté en 2008
suite au décès de raymond forni
mais ce n'est que deux ans plus tard en
2010 qu'elle gagne la légitimité des
urnes en étant reconduite à la tête de
sa région après une triangulaire déjà
avec la droite et le fn
sous régional marie-guite dufay et mère
de trois enfants
passionné de sport et notamment de ski
elle aime travailler dans la discrétion
mais se laisse aussi filmé en pleine
séance de relaxation un jour d'élection
une simplicité qui participent au style
du fait dans son action cet ancien cadre
de la npa a logiquement fait de l'emploi
sa spécialité les questions du chômage
m'a toujours hanté la question de
l'emploi qu'elle ne répond pas avec des
baguettes magiques mais avec méthode
c'est par notre première compétence qui
est la formation qu'on peut amener
quelque chose on peut amener de la
protection on peut amener de
l'information pour les emplois qui
émergent on peut amener la compétence
dont les entreprises ont besoin
donc il faut d'arrache-pied continuer
depuis un an elle a travaillé à la
fusion des régions de concert avec son
homologue bourguignon françois patriat
un temps son concurrent avant de
renoncer à conduire la gauche aux
régionales
à 66 ans marie-guite dufay a réussi son
pari elle est et restera la première
présidente de la bourgogne franche comté
et comme pour faire le trait d'union
d'emblée ce matin elle est vite reparti
vers besançon et nous retrouvons
justement marie-guite dufay en duplex
depuis besançon marie-guite dufay
nous avons vécu et vous avez vécu une
campagne difficile
abu avant d'aborder la politique pure
une question plus personnelle de quoi
êtes vous le plus fier au lendemain de
cette élection
je suis fier du soutien que j'ai reçu d'
mobilisation qu'il y avait autour de moi
ce fut un travail collectif et je me
suis sentie portait vraiment par
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de militants
beaucoup de sympathisants
beaucoup d'électeurs je me suis senti
porté par ma famille ma famille qui
vraiment que je remercie énormément que
jérémy chevreuil marie-guite dufay
on vous a entendu hier soir célébrer la
victoire de la gauche vous ne dites pas
la victoire du parti socialiste pourquoi
cette nuance mais c'est la gauche
notre combat le parti socialiste il lui
manque les écologistes et le parti
communiste là je regrette cela nous
allons avoir une assemblée très
démocratique avec
représentant de l'extrême droite et
représentants de la droite et puis nous
aurons le parti socialiste sans les
écologistes et sans le parti communiste
ça je le regrette énormément
est-ce que vous souhaitez du coup les
associés d'une manière ou d'une autre à
la gestion de la région
il faudra il faudra que nous trouvions
les moyens je ne sais pas lesquels
encore mais en tout cas la corde
soutient que nous avons conclus et qui
aurait dû être un accord de fusion doit
être un accord engageant et je m'y
engage
et il faudra je trouve les moyens pour
que nous nous travaillons ensemble
c'est à inventer mais il est du fait on
sait que l'entre-deux tours a été très
tendue le front national avait viré en
tête
est ce qu'à un moment donné dans cette
campagne vous aviez envisagé en fonction
des résultats peut-être un retrait comme
c'est arrivé dans d'autres régions où
est ce que ça ne vous a jamais effleuré
j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de le dire
la question du retrait m'a effleuré
si nous n'avions aucune chance de
l'emporter face au front national et à
partir du moment où j'ai vu les
résultats définitifs et où j'ai vu que
c'était possible et je n'ai pas voulu
déserter le combat politique
j'ai voulu le mener je savais que
c'était un combat difficile
je les dis le front national avait des
chances de gagner la gauche aussi
mais elle avait aussi des chances de
perdre j'ai mené ce combat vous avez
senti une mobilisation très forte à
gauche dans l'entre-deux tours on va
dire est ce que les appareils
socialistes se sont mis en marche à ce
moment là mais c'est pas que les
appareils
tout le monde s'est mis en marche les
militants dont c'est le premier travail
pendant une élection effectivement ont
été formidables ils ont fait un travail
d'arrache-pied mais j'ai senti la
population s'ils se mobilisent et je
vais sentir chaque fois que je suis allé
à la rencontre de la population que ce
soit à audincourt que ce soit à vesoul
que ce soit à chalon sur saône
j'ai senti cette mobilisation je sentais
que les gens avaient envie de parler et
ça ça fait du bien parce que pendant
tout le reste de la campagne
on n'entendait plus cette envie de
parler de la part des gens nous avons
fait un peu une campagne comme si
c'était dans le vide
on distribue
et on essayait d'aller au devant des la
population et ça ne fonctionnait pas et
ça fonctionne encore moins après les
attentats je crois qu'il y à vraiment à
renouer ce fils avec les électeurs c'est
extrêmement important parce que notre
démocratie on a besoin si on ne rejoue
pas le lien avec le politique politique
qui est le le service du bien commun le
souci de l'intérêt général
eh bien on va être en grave difficulté
avant de poursuivre avec vous mme arguer
du fait je vous propose d'écouter ces
réactions celle de vos employés au
conseil régional de franche-comté des
fonctionnaires qui garderont donc la
même patronne emmanuel rivals 1 avec
fabien fougères c'est un lundi
forcément pas comme les autres pour les
fonctionnaires du conseil régional 8
heures ce matin les premiers arrivés ne
s'attardent guère d'autres confient leur
soulagement après la réélection de leur
président sur la félicite barrage au fn
génial soulagés franchement soulagé oui
la veille d'attitude par rapport au
front national bien sûr on avait peur
qu'avec la bourgogne voilà c'était
sauvadet en bourgogne on soit un petit
peu oubliée onze heures marie-guite
dufay pousse les portes du conseil
régional de retour de dijon visiblement
la nuit a été courte attendus n'ont pas
non parce que je pense qu'il ya la
tension qui empêche de devenir non je
peux pas dire que j'ai très bien dormi
comme elle le fait tous les matins la
présidente de région se dirige alors
très vite vers ses collaborateurs les
plus proches
une fois dans son bureau
elle jette un coup d'oeil sur les
journaux qui pour la plupart parlent
d'une victoire sur le fil
ric rac la présidente n'apprécie pas
vraiment 4,32 en normandie c'est c'est
0,2 point d'écart
donc là on dit quoi certains journaux
ont même parlé d'une roulette russe
c'est comment l'expression la roulette
russe
ça ça m'a fait mal on n'a pas joué à la
roulette russe
on s'est battu on s'est battu
marie-guite dufay a ensuite entamé sa
journée de travail un nouveau mandat
les vacances attendront marie-guite
dufay y aura-t-il de la place pour
quelques jours de vacances où vous
retrouverez les dossiers dès aujourd'hui
oui je l'espère je l'espère j'ai trop
besoin de mes petits enfants et de mes
enfants alors marie-guite dufay vous
êtes à nouveau travailler ce qu'on peut
voir ce matin vous avez travaillé sur
des dossiers aussi bourguignon vous êtes
encore cantonnée à la franche comté
je suis présidente de la franche-comté
jusqu'à la fin de du mois de même que
françois patriat et président de la
bourgogne jusqu'à la fin de ce mois
c'est un peu la curiosité un de notre
système institutionnel mais c'est ainsi
je ne serai président de la bourgogne
franche comté qu'à partir du 4 janvier
du fait on sait que en termes juridiques
la capitale administrative et à dijon ce
qui veut dire que normalement le siège
du conseil régional est déconnecté il
devrait être à besançon en franche comté
est ce que vous allez proposer au vote
de la nouvelle assemblée que le siège
viennent à dijon ou pas écoutez cela
fera partie des débats de la future
assemblée puisque c'est à la fin du
semestre que nous devons nous prononcer
sur cette question est quelle est votre
position personnelle j'ai besoin d'en
débattre et que ce soit l'addition la
décision soit issu d'un débat collectif
une question aussi sur cette grande
région vous avez dit ça a été dur
faire campagne de parler aux gens alors
il y avait le contexte est ce qu'il y
avait aussi la difficulté d'identité de
cette nouvelle région est ce que vous
avez des idées pour que cette nouvelle
région elle trouve une identité
maintenant j'ai pas trop senti cela je
sens bien sûr qu'en franche-comté on a
toujours besoin d'être rassurés par
rapport à la future grande région en
bourgogne j'aime beaucoup moins senti
cela et cette question de la grande
région et du devenir de la grande région
à mon avis on a moins pesé sur la
difficulté du débat que la question
purement politique
on sent des amours une désaffection
vis-à-vis du politique qui est énorme et
qui est extrêmement grave
mais ce qu'il faut c'est que nous
travaillons avec tous les territoires
c'est ma position cela fait partie de
mes engagements si on veut réaliser
cette grande région
il faut que nous fassions ce qui est le
métier de la grande région d'être au
contact de toutes les initiatives de les
favoriser de les pousser dans tous les
territoires qu'ils soient urbains ou
ruraux et cela va nécessiter pour une
très grande réactivité une organisation
beaucoup plus décentralisée qu'elle ne
l'était jusqu'à maintenant
merci marie-guite dufay en duplex et en
direct de besançon avec nous en direct
ici
michel neugnot alain suguenot l'appareil
peut-être vous d'abord alain suguenot
on a donné la parole à la gauche côté
droite maintenant pour elle est rude et
les stèles et rudy arrivé à deuxième
hier quel sera votre rôle dans cette
nouvelle assemblée
comment vous allez construire cette
opposition à droite dans un premier
temps j'aurais félicité la nouvelle
présidente c'est la tradition
républicaine
une pensée aussi pour françois sauvadet
parce que une triangulaire c'est une
triangulaire il n'y a pas à mon avis de
grandes victoires dans une triangulaire
avec la loi proportionnelle l'opposition
va faire son travail
nous étions déjà dans une région à
l'époque en bourgogne mais également en
franche comté et qui étaient gérées par
les socialistes donc faire faire le
travail de représentation des
territoires
la grande inquiétude pour cette élection
j'entendais
du fait dire que c'était essentiellement
la politique n'y a pas que la politique
est aussi les décisions qui ont été
prises et la grande région et kate et je
lui souhaite du courage non seulement
pour des raisons politiques mais
également parce que c'est une majorité
de 51 49
avec un front national qui est puissant
dans ces conditions ça ne sera pas
forcément un long fleuve tranquille donc
16 ans pendant laquelle je crois que les
républicains et lui dis donc
l'alliance qui s'est fait lors de cette
élection va devoir être une force de
proposition pour les bourguignons parce
que je crois qu'il faut déjà penser aux
territoires
la grande inquiétude des territoires je
crois que c'est peut-être qu'on a oublié
dans les débats depuis hier soir c'est
en effet qu'il ya une inquiétude
l'éloignement et les grandes régions
font partie également je pense du vote
un peu d'inquiétude qu'ont d'ailleurs au
coeur au premier tour alain suguenot
est-ce que vous devez ou pas revoir
votre logiciel
est ce que on doit considérer encore que
le front national c'est quelque chose
qui serait un prolongement de la droite
républicaine et qu' il peut y avoir un
certain nombre de mouvements ou est-ce
que ce qui s'est passé hier soir c'est à
dire en réalité le front national qui a
progressé entre les deux tours pour
arriver un score jamais atteint dans
notre région et leur troisième place ne
doit pas le masquer est-ce que ça doit
vous obligez vous droite républicaine on
posera la question aussi à la gauche
mais à vous poser ces questions-là
bien évidemment je crois que ça date pas
d'aujourd'hui l'impression de se
surprendre de l'augmentation
bien sûr des suffrages pour le front
national est-ce que ça doit entraîner
quelque chose sur le discours c'est là
la question de par exemple la position
de nicolas sarkozy allant sur des thèmes
qui semblait à ceux du front national
mais tout le monde parle de ça je crois
que mais c'est pas l'histoire du lit ni
c'est pas tout ça la question
d'aujourd'hui c'est qu'il ya une grande
inquiétude nos compatriotes et les
problèmes territoriaux sont aussi
importants qu'on éloigne aujourd'hui
l'impression que les décisions sont
prises à paris quelle que soit
d'ailleurs les familles politiques
je pense que c'est cette inquiétude là
qui ressort là aujourd'hui tout le monde
a gagné en fin de compte tout le monde a
perdu
tout le monde a perdu le front national
n'a pas pu bien évidemment conquérir une
région mais même s'il a progressé en
voix ronde est d'accord le parti
socialiste a évité le pire en gardant
entre guillemets y compris la bourgogne
franche comté
les républicains ont gagné parce qu'ils
ont cette région alors qu'il n'avait
qu'une aujourd'hui donc le vrai problème
c'est qu'ils sont les perdants mais les
perdants c'est effectivement peut-être
comme le
la nouvelle présidente le politique
parce que justement on peut se poser la
question de savoir si les décisions
parisienne est ce qu'elles sont entendus
aujourd'hui au niveau le catch hawks est
plus que jamais nécessaire d'avoir une
vraie politique sur les territoires pour
le monde rural
je crois qu'on a peu entendu et on a vu
les votes on n'est pas aidés ville parce
que les villes ont voté plus tôt leur
sensibilité mais les zones rurales ont
l'impression d'être abandonné
aujourd'hui on va leur dire justement
permis d enseignement de ce scrutin
alain suguenot vous disiez la victoire
de la gauche est acquise notamment grâce
aux grandes villes dont certaines plutôt
ancré à droite ou prise par la droite
aux élections municipales l'an dernier
comme en saône et loire à chalon sur
saône ou à montceau-les-mines
intéressons nous à la ville de montceau
où le front national est arrivé en tête
au premier tour le ps troisième meir
l'ordre s'est totalement inversée vous
le voyez marie guite dufay a largement
distancé françois sauvadet avec 36,2
33,8 pour elle est rude et y ait 30 pour
sophie montel la fête à gauche dans une
ville passait à droite
fanny borius gabriel devant la mairie de
montceau faisait grise mine hier
présente lors du dépouillement la mère a
eu du mal à cacher sa déception
si elle garde le sourire au moment de
déclarer les résultats l'opposition
explose de joie
déçu oui forcément
forcément surprise surprise oui un peu
parce que je trouve que ce report de
voir il est il est terriblement sévère
il est terriblement sévère je pense
qu'il s'est fait surtout pour faire
diminuer le front national avec cette
peur sur le front national
l est républicain et le centre en
mompati montceau une ville de droite qui
avait le coeur à gauche hier et où la
mairie celui de transformer en salle des
fêtes
moi je suis vraiment heureux parce que
pour moi la compétence première de la
région c'est les lycées et demain je me
dis que mon lycée il sera pas gérée par
le front national c'est des subventions
qu'on va pouvoir gagner sur des robes
internationale de nos filières et tout
ça on est aujourd'hui à 3 points devant
le le maire de cette ville qui par
ailleurs est deuxième de liste sur la
liste de sauvadet
voilà je crois qu'aujourd'hui c'est la
victoire de toute cette équipe qu'il ya
derrière moi c'est avant tout une
victoire collective parce que c'est la
victoire du travail depuis 18 mois nous
travaillons tous les dossiers la fête
s'est ensuite déplacé au local ps de la
ville ou anciens maires et élus locaux
se sont retrouvés pour traquer à la
victoire
sans oublier le score important du front
national qui progresse très légèrement
au second tour
donc c'est une non c'est vrai que ce
soir d'abord la fête on devra pas se
contenter d'une victoire il faut
analyser tout ça
hier l'opposition penser déjà aux
municipales prévues dans un peu plus de
quatre ans et parmi les personnalités
très impliqués dans cette campagne et
investit également dans
l'entre-deux-tours françois rebsamen le
maire de dijon analysé hier soir ici
même sur france 3 ce scrutin avec cette
distinction entre le vote urbain et
rural dans notre région il ya deux
électorats différents et un électorat
qui a un électorat rural qui donne sa
préférence qui donnait sa préférence à
la droite et qui donne sa préférence en
ce moment plutôt à l'extrême droite est
à la droite c'est vrai et la gauche et
est derrière est distancé et puis il ya
les l'électorat des villes des
communautés urbaines des communautés
d'agglomération qui donne une large
majorité à la gauche
pourquoi si vous me le permettez en deux
je pense que de dépeindre sans arrêt le
monde je les dis à françois sauvadet de
dépeindre sans arrêt le monde rural
comme le lieu du misérabilisme le lieu
où ça ne va pas ou c'est tout pour les
autres alors qu on est en responsabilité
du monde rural puisque quand on a les
départements on est en responsabilité du
monde rural
c'est finalement c'est finalement faire
le lit de l'extrême droite parce que si
comme vous dirigez à département vous
pensez que les zones rurales ne vont pas
bien
et bien c'est avouent qu'elles vont leur
reprocher et c'est ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui donc il est temps de se
ressaisir
alors jérémy chauveau arriveront
justement les chiffres dans certaines
grandes villes de bourgogne et de
franche-comté france françois rebsamen a
dit à un marié dufay a cartonné dans les
vignes dans les fiefs du ps dijon mais
aussi besançon 52% en triangulaire c'est
très important mais aussi dans des
villes de droite marie-guite dufay est
en tête à chalon sur saône à belfort à
lons certains étaient candidats mais
aussi sur les talons vraiment de marie
guide de françois sauvadet à mâcon ou à
vesoul vesoul qui est quand même le fief
d'alain joyandet qui était le chef de
file régional dé l'air pour ce cette
grande région bourgogne france comté
alors effectivement réussite dans les
villes
michel neugnot mais on l'a dit gros
déficit dans les campagnes qu'est ce que
vous avez raté depuis que la gauche est
au gouvernement avec le monde rural
moi je pense que dans le monde rural
il y à la température ressentie
ayez la réalité je crois que quand on
parle d'abandon des services publics
dans le monde rural
le travail qui a été fait par toutes les
intercommunalités un nid du service
public et du service public pour toutes
les générations
par contre quand on faire une perception
qu aucune postes risquent de fermer
d'ailleurs y aura certainement une
révolution qui est en train de se faire
au niveau de la poste avec les courriers
électroniques qui vont remplacer cris et
bien là il ya un sentiment de
désespérance de désespoir parce que ce
sont des symboles qui abandonne le monde
rural mais quand on regarde la réalité
je prends pour la petite enfance
pour la la restauration scolaire pour
les transports pour les personnes âgées
pour tout ce que l'on peut apporter
comme confort le service public et le
service au public comme il y aura lé est
quand même important alors tout est dans
la confiance dans le politique saisir
cela n'est pas vraiment ressenti n'ai
pas vraiment ressenti et je crois qu'il
y avait effectivement une forme de le de
débats de diallo qui est à faire avec
les territoires
est ce que nous proposons ce que nous
allons faire ça se bat sur le dialogue
social territorial au conseil régional
peut intervenir là dessus c'est à dire
on est en partenariat avec l'ensemble
des territoires sauf que les populations
ne savent pas forcément
est ce que l'on a mis au centre de notre
de notre gouvernance c'est de se
rapprocher des territoires de profiter
du fait connu une grande région pour se
rapprocher des territoires et à voir
dans chaque territoire on attend par
territoire bassin de vie bassin d'emploi
de mettre les choses à plat
il est faux de dire que aucun terrible
que les territoires n'ont plus d'avenir
tous les territoires où qu'il soit ou un
avenir et le rôle de la région est de
voir quels sont les pépites
quels sont les graines que l'on doit
faire germer et ça ça doit se faire dans
le dialogue où il l'a fait pour partie
en bourgogne et franche comté sur les
prennent de formation et autres il faut
avoir un débat approfondi avec les
territoires et à partir d'une analyse de
la situation voir comment les aider et d
appuyer là je crois que c'est ça
l'avenir à droite maintenant
hier soir françois sauvadet s'est
exprimé sur la défaite depuis son qg de
campagne dijonnais il est arrivé au
premier tour en deuxième position il
espérait jusqu'au bout réunir la droite
et le centre sur son nom c'est donc une
déception pour le président du conseil
départemental de la côte d'or françois
sauvadet arrive en tête en bourgogne
mais troisième en franche comté et c'est
son troisième échec lors d'élections
régionales retour sur cette soirée avec
et sébastien kérou et christophe
gaillard
à l'annoncé des résultats les soutiens
de françois sauvadet font grise mine
un demi point sépare le candidat de
l'union de la droite de marie-guite
dufay à 20 heures malgré cette défaite
annoncée
les militants garde espoir on a des
estimations carrière au compte gouttes
les votes de l'agglo sont pas terminées
tous les espoirs sont fermés autre
mauvaise surprise le front national qui
a gagné des voix supplémentaires
au deuxième tour on a un front national
est extrêmement fort en moré pour
scouter sa sevré provocation et je pense
qu'il faudra effectivement réfléchir à
un moyen de retrouver pour lutter contre
ce phénomène
au fil des minutes les résultats tombent
la droite distancé par marie-guite dufay
ne remportera pas la région bourgogne
franche comté le maire de beaune est
amère mais reste fair play pourquoi on a
des scores aussi important sur d'autres
régions ce que ya eu un désistement la
désistement de beaulieu je me mets à la
place des socialistes s'ils lisent après
tout on a eu raison
c'est comme ça qu'on gagne région qui
s'appelle death et tout s'éclaire mois
s'est fixé votre ainsi que le meilleur
gagne
si l'arrivée du fait aimer ce soir
qu'ils ont de féliciter 21h30 françois
sauvadet retrouve enfin ses militants
celui qui était encore favori il ya un
mois doit reconnaître sa défaite
j'assume l'entière responsabilité de
cette campagne
ils ont perdu peu mais nous avons perdu
de demain nous allons nous remettre au
travail ensemble au service de la côte
d'or
je participe aux travaux du conseil
régional je lui dis je démissionnerais
le mandat parlementaire je les annonces
et je respecterai mes engagements je
veux dire à tous ceux qui m'ont fait
confiance que nous continuerons de nous
battre pendant ces six années
une défaite lourde à digérer pour les
républicains élus dei pour les militants
la nuit sera difficile alain suguenot
françois sauvadet est il fini on a
d'autres exemples je crois que françois
a mené un combat courageux c'est vrai
que c'était la troisième fois
il n'empêche que c'est une nouvelle
région
ce qui était considéré comme un père
date par votre camp il ya quelques
années encore que l'on pouvait pas
prévoir les attentats de paris comme
vous pouvez pas prouver la dramatiser
sur monsieur valls que vous pourrez pas
prévoir effectivement bien sûr tout ce
qui est arrivé depuis un mois je crois
qu'on est dans un contexte très
particulier
et quand on regarde les différences sur
aujourd'hui les résultats je disais tout
à l'heure il n'y a pas de victoire
salaires udi qui n'a pas marché parce
que non mais je crois que l'union est
obligatoire je pense qu'un scrutin comme
celui d'hier montre au contraire qu'il
faut se rassembler la gauche je dis
c'est plus que nécessaire à droite
il s'agit pas de savoir si c'est le ni
ni qui l'a emporté ou l'averse je crois
qu'aujourd'hui c'est vraiment une
réponse à apporter on le disait tout à
l'heure aux françaises et aux français
et je reviens dessus dit tout à l'heure
que les villes de rester fier la gauche
je suis le contre exemple si aussi des
villes et des agglomérations dans
lesquelles la droite républicaine long
pantalon sur son mari du fait en tête je
suis le candidat bien dire que sur les
territoires ruraux canton des proches et
je reviens cette nouvelle région et
c'est bien sûr le sens très atténuantes
pour françois sauvadet en bourgogne
françois sauvadet gagné le prix ainsi
que cette nouvelle région avec le
désamour des francos toit pour les
mourinho est peut-être à la verte et
bourrignon pour les franc comtois je
crois que c'est il faut absorber toutes
ces réformes c'est à dire qu'il ya un
problème avec la droite en franche comté
il ya eu probablement un problème dans
des villes de droite mais pas qu'en
franche-comté je crois que il faut bien
évidemment considérer qu' il ya des
échecs qui ont été sur certains
territoires
le vrai problème c'est de savoir une
campagne régionale c'est aussi pas
simplement la campagne d'une tête de
liste françois sauvadet sutil campagne
des militants de celles et ceux qui font
le travail sur le terrain j'aurais
remercier nos militants il n'empêche
qu'il y ait des villes ou émeraude est
dit on pouvait faire beaucoup mieux
autre camp l'espoir de victoire s'est
effondré le front national un colt 32 4%
des suffrages mais le parti arrivé
largement en tête au premier tour gan
tout de même des voix et des élus 24 au
total contre 10 en bourgogne et en
franche-comté jusqu alors justin sakho
et de nicole ont suivi hier sophie
montel et les militants
sophie montel tout sourire malgré la
défaite
arrivé en troisième position derrière
marie-guite dufay françois sauvadet la
tête de liste frontiste ne sera pas
présidente de bourgogne franche comté
mais hier soir à 21h dans son qg de rang
la candidate ne s'avouait pas vaincu
c'est pas le peuple qui nous a
sanctionnés c'est pas le peuple qui qui
a voté qui a fait barrage au front
national ce soir ce sont les élites une
nouvelle fois les présidents
d'université qui envoyait des courriers
aux étudiants les grands patrons ces
élections régionales nous ont démontré
que le front national avait malgré tout
et malgré tous le vent en poupe et que
le changement c'est nous et c'est pour
bientôt
largement en tête du premier tour la
franc comtoise avait commencé sa journée
électorale à saint-vite seul mais
sereine coup sûr de toutes nos chansons
19h30 dans le qg frontiste jurassien ici
sophie montel est en tête mais très vite
les visages sont crispés
le taux de participation a explosé de
plus de 10 points par rapport au premier
tour
un mauvais signe pour le fn mais à 21h
la défaite a un goût de victoire
le front national a gagné 73 mille voix
par rapport au premier tour j'avais peur
que ses ventes ont dévissé donc
il n'y a plus de gauche il n'y a plus de
droite le vieux système est explosé on
est en train de changer de paradigme
le front national se présente comme une
innovation radicale et beaucoup de gens
vont continuer à l'adopter parce que
c'est la solution la seule solution face
au mondialisme à l'économie financière
mondialisée
le barrage n'a pas tellement bien
fonctionné puisque seuls contre tous
nous augmentons quand notre score ce
soir
le danger est toujours là
mobilisons-nous la tête de liste ironise
et se félicite d'être en tête dans trois
départements de la grande région
les zones rurales où on a cartonné au
premier tour nous en faisons pas la
chaîne de continuer son continu et ne
portait plus ou encore la bourgogne
franche comté restera une terre
socialiste mais 24 conseillers porteront
désormais les voix du fn dans la grande
région
13h30 en direct sur france 3 dans cette
édition spéciale élections régionales en
trouveront dans un instant et christian
paul député socialiste frondeurs en
direct de paris
d'abord les commentaires sur les réseaux
sociaux à vezins sélection de messages
postés ce matin des textes mais aussi
des photos mais regardez d'abord ces
clichés postés par françois rebsamen
cette nuit c'était au cellier de
clairvaux à dijon le maire socialiste et
d'autres élus qui ont acclamé
marie-guite dufay alors la gauche qui
conserve la bourgogne franche comté
forcément ça plaît à pierre moscovici
ancien député du doubs aujourd'hui à
bruxelles
heureux du sursaut du deuxième tour des
régionales écrit-il et du refus du fn
maintenant place aux projets et les
solutions dans la nièvre
c'est plus nuancé gaëtan gorce et son
style c'est pas moi je fais des temps
morts ce qui est écrit je remercie les
nivernaise pour leur mobilisation
un immense travail reste à faire
écrit-il
la droite elle accuse le coup regarder
ce tweet de chalon charles d'astorg
proche de guillaume la vie river qui
parle de tristesse qui dit qu'il faut se
remettre en question du côté de la
droite c'est sportif du côté de chalon
gilles platret le maire lui évoque une
coque 21 calendrier ultra politiciens
nous remportons cette région sur 12 ça
s'appelle une victoire dit le maire les
républicains
même son de cloche du côté du front
national regarder ce tweet d'art un
corps nu candidat frontiste dans le jura
le fn premier parti de france et sans
aucune alliance
on va terminer avec une der un dernier
message regardez c'est un dessin de
david l'anneau du grès ancien candidat
aux municipales de dijon on a évité le
pire mais toujours pas de trace du
meilleur merci elle a d'autres réactions
avec nos invités toujours en direct de
besançon cette fois avec catherine aime
série katherine oui merci arnaud oui ici
à besançon nous avons sur ce plateau
trois nouveaux conseillers régionaux de
la grande région bourgogne franche comté
mais ils viennent tous les trois de
franche comté
nous avons tout d'abord à tout d'abord
arnaud mart sc le maire socialiste de
baume les dames face à lui se trouve
julien akaro conseiller municipal
d'opposition à besançon et il est front
national et puis jean philippe lefebvre
adjoint à la culture de dole qui est
donc adhérents aux républicains on va
commencer ce débat avec vous jean
philippe lefebvre on entendait quelqu'un
donc de l air en bourgogne qui disait
que des voix avait manqué à françois
sauvadet en franche comté et que
certaines villes n'avaient pas joué le
jeu
donc la droite est battue par
marie-guite dufay à lons à belfort à
montbéliard à dole des villes détenues
par la droite dont dole la vôtre comment
vous expliquer d'abord si on devait
parler du cas de dole françois sauvadet
tête en tête au premier tour et je pense
que c'est c'est justement une un bon une
bonne illustration
clairement la gauche c'est beaucoup
mieux mobiliser que la droite et si on
prend l'exemple de loin les les bureaux
de gauche très clairement on ont connu
une augmentation de la de la
particiation ça veut dire que d'auxillac
gauche a mobilisé plus vous l'avez
jamais vu venir et moi c'est finalement
ça qui m'intéresse c'est pourquoi
pourquoi là
la droite et le centre n'ont pas réussi
finalement à mobiliser autant autant que
nos adversaires pour pour pour plusieurs
raisons la première est sa me ça me
perturbe moi qui suis un gaulliste qui
appartient au parti qui a rétabli deux
fois la république en 1944 en 1958 et
aujourd'hui ma famille c'est laisser
voler depuis 30 ou 40 ans finalement ce
rôle qu'elle avait de représenter la
république est clairement pas requis par
le fonds national par tout le monde
je dois dire que les socialistes ont
cette capacité absolument incroyable a
utilisé dès qu'ils le peuvent le modo
république de démocratie d'humanisme
nous nous sommes quoi nous sommes des
démographes sur les lieux sans musique
un syndrome issus des démocrates
chrétiens nous sommes issus des
gaullistes celui-ci des libéraux et nous
sommes issus des radicaux ces quatre
femmes il a finalement après tout ont su
construire la république et aujourd'hui
c'est vrai que nous sommes
inaudible quand on veut le défendre et
puis quand nos adversaires socialistes
appellent au rassemblement parce que la
république serait menacé
ça marche ça marche ça marche est
clairement alors j'ai les républiques
interpellé n'ont pas appelé à voter non
plus socialiste dans l'air dans les
régions qui sur lesquels les socialistes
s'étaient désistés je trouve votre
argumentation vous êtes vous est à la
ramasse excusez moi de vous le dire vous
vous dites que la gauche donne des
leçons de république et démocratie vous
venez de rebaptiser votre propre
mouvement les républicains mairie donc
je suis désolé mais met une fois de plus
vous illustrez ici là la proximité
idéologique avec le parti socialiste et
vous mais était parfaitement le nom du
mps alors vous aviez votre petit
argumentaire il est facile on le connaît
vous savez on est on pourrait vous mais
vous monsieur le faire parler vous avez
un siège de plus tout va bien
car qu'est ce qui a manqué au front
national pour l'emporter hier
ben pas grand chose j'ai envie de vous
dire ça se joue dans un mouchoir de
poche
la commande et la progression que l'on
fait au second tour est exceptionnel
plus de soixante quinze mille voix entre
les deux tours est effectivement sophie
montel le disais dans leurs reportages
juste avant ce sont les élites qui ont
mobilisé autour d'elle la presse les
grands patrons et puis et puis toute
cette clique par exemple les prisons
diverses d'université qui ont encore
rappelé lors leurs étudiants a voté
massivement pour le parti socialiste
donc cette petite île les très
nombreuses en fait dans une série c'est
à dire que l'élite n'est pas forcément
nombreuses mais elles mobilisent voilà
et je pense que cela étant dit c'est
moins vrai et ça le sera de moins en
moins et nous allons faire la
démonstration avec force avec no 24 élus
au conseil régional de bourgogne franche
comté effectivement de cette clique
arnaud mart est donc je disais tout à
l'heure une partie du parti socialiste
j'arrive vous dire ouf à oui quelque
sorte on peut on peut dire ça c'est
vraiment une victoire on peut pas non
plus complètement satisfaire le contexte
est difficile et vous dit merci au front
national permet de mobiliser votre camp
comme vis-à-vis des banques et les
chiffres de mobilisation ces deux cent
mille euros
deux cent mille pardons et doctorants en
plus 75 pour le fn entre les deux tours
et 150 pour les républicains
évidemment qu'ils aient un effet
mobilisateur important dans notre
électorat et qui a dit ben ok on se
mobilisent parce qu'on ne veut pas du
front national mais de cela il faut en
faire quelque chose court comme un repas
secrétaires et en même temps les
rencontres et il ne donne pas un
blanc-seing
et ça va être un challenge très
difficile à relever
surtout que c'est surtout une politique
qui a été nationalisé sur le scrutin là
je l'évoquais c'était une campagne
difficile et on a plus parlé du fait
national d'art proposition la montée du
front national que le bilan était quand
même désastreux du parti socialiste
autant aux exécutifs bourguignon que
franc comtois donc ça vous a plutôt bien
arrangé fermées elles vont le débat je
pense que oui ça c'est nationalisées et
quelque part il ya une mobilisation qui
nous a fait gagner c'est pas un
blanc-seing ça va être un challenge
difficile et au delà de la recomposition
nationale c'est comment localement avec
des politiques régionales qui sont
concrètes
sur les transports sur la formation
professionnelle le développement
économique l'aménagement du territoire
on va pouvoir répondre une forme de
désespérance d'inquiétude qu'on a bien
sentis qui est difficile et donc aux
citoyens on voit ça va être difficile
parce que la région va être encore plus
grande on a vu que les campagnes votent
massivement front national le lien peut
être encore en encore plus distendus
entre dijon besançon et les territoires
ruraux
lalala s'il ya une vraie inquiétude et
je pense que cette grande région dit
allez faire quoi elle peut faire peur
notamment si on recrée et ça ça serait
un vrai danger je l'évoqué quelquefois
de recréer une technostructure
administrative régionale est quelque
chose qui s'éloigne du coin de nos
concitoyens ça serait vraiment un drame
ça c'est certain
donc il faudra qu'on invente quelque
chose qui qui nous rapproche qui sont à
proximité qui se base sur les élus
locaux sur nos associations sur les
acteurs de la visite jean philippe la
femme sauf que dans votre campagne alors
d'abord je crois que pour revenir comme
à la campagne
d'abord peut-être on va peut-être parler
de ce qui va lui maintenant mais vous
avez vous oublié comment est totalement
bouleversée oui on peut remédier à ça
que quand on quand on explique que des
villes de droite ou aujourd'hui ont
changé on peut pas faire de projections
sur les municipales à quatre ans et
c'est juste c'est juste impossible parce
qu'on est dans un contexte tout à fait
particulier
le rêve pour revenir sur la la question
de la proximité
vous vous défendez l'idée qu'il convient
de défendre une marque bourgogne franche
comté et le seul fait de défendre cette
idée là c'est justement celle qui
consiste à créer une nouvelle structure
quelque chose qui va s'empiler une super
région et je pense qu'effectivement la y
avait un vrai risque est qu'au delà des
mots que vous utilisez si on s'engage et
qu'on respecte pas les deux identités
celle de la bourgogne est celle de la
franche comté qui sont gérés simplement
par une entité qui est un conseil
régional qui est unique qu on prendra un
vrai concrètement vous allez être
l'opposant numéro un vous l air d y du
parti socialiste à la région par semaine
et ça les a joués à ce qu'on va jouer on
va jouer notre lui que vous le vouliez
ou non ça fait de toute façon à peu près
60 ans dans l'histoire on a été est dans
l'opposition et dans la majorité on sait
aussi tenir notre place dans
l'opposition ça pose aucun problème
autrement des délibérations avec le haut
et régionaux présentés sortant qui ne
prennent pas la parole ne prennent pas
part au revoir et et de raconter
n'importe quoi ce que vous dites que le
soleil simplement cela enfin avec sa
muse jane d'écouter l'opposition une
opposition rigoureuse consciencieuse et
sans concession donc ça veut dire que
vous serez présent bien des cyprès au
vol mais qu'aucune n'est pas forcément
le cas où que ces régionales non mais
enfin je supprime tout vous sortez ça
écoute mais phase de sevrage
je m'en excuse non parce que moi cette
occasion ces régionales et position d
assister aux séances du sénat note du
front national sont très claires nous
n'avons pas voté 95 % des délibérations
c'est que je n'avais pas aider vous
n'avez vous pas voter les aides aux
entreprises vous n'avez pas aidé des
aides aux eaux à l'artisanat et vous et
vous essayez c'est comme ça que nous en
disant vote pour le front national c'est
évident monsieur vous avez une bonne
analyse mais continue mais c'est mais
c'est vrai que c'est là le débat il est
là des binômes art est donc on voit une
opposition donc 25 sièges pour l heure
des 24 pour le front national
une majorité plus que courte 51 sièges
vous allez faire comment je crois qu'il
faut convaincre c'est l'essentiel comme
la main votre voisin de droite
je crois qu'on va mener une politique
qui se base sur ce qu'on a viré annoncé
concitoyens on a fait des propositions
sont dix engagements on a des
propositions claires pour la région et
vous avez vu d'ailleurs et je pense que
ça a pu aussi faire le la balance et et
je pense la crédibilité marie-guite
dufay c'est le fait qu'elle était
classée comme la présidente de région
qui a le plus respecté ses engagements
lors du précédent mandat et je crois
qu'il faut faire simple simple et
efficace
c'est à dire le monde qui sait le
quotidien le journal le monde qui le
précédait je crois que ça aussi rendu on
a besoin de rendre crédit la parole
publique essentiellement quand même de
la responsabilité que vous avez compte
tenu justement de se dire distendus avec
les électeurs n'est pas le droit
d'échouer
incroyable mais cette responsabilité
politique on l'a mais qu'on soit un
simple élu local ou comme moi ou nos
responsables nationaux encore plus et
demain une recomposition de la vie
politique est nécessaire c'est certain
on peut pas se contenter
j'irai de ce choc qu'on a vécu au
premier tour mais c'est il ya une
nécessité de refonte
de la vie politique c'est vraiment et je
crois que pour tous les partis qui sont
aussi autour de la table c'est une
nécessité évidemment que aujourd'hui et
vu le contexte actuel
les événements récents ont rendu les
choses encore plus prégnante
il va falloir que l'on travaille
activement à tout cela et on surveillera
très attentivement les prochaines
séances du conseil régional de bourgogne
franche comté la voirie catherine la
direction paris à présent on nous attend
christian paul député socialiste de la
nièvre voix des frondeurs christian paul
le patron du parti socialiste jean
christophe cambadélis demande au
gouvernement une inflexion dans les 18
mois à venir nous ne pouvons plus
continuer comme cela at il déclaré il
rejoint ce que vous dite depuis
longtemps finalement oui c'est important
d'entendre que les idées que nous
défendons depuis de longs mois ont fait
leur chemin et qu'elles sont aujourd'hui
portés aussi par le premier secrétaire
du parti socialiste mais si vous me le
permettez parce que je suis d'abord un
citoyen et un élus de la nièvre de la
bourgogne franche comté et du monde
rural
je voudrais vous dire que j'ai vraiment
je suis très heureux bien sûr de la
victoire de toute l'équipe qui entoure
marie-guite dufay que nous l'attendons
notre nouvelle présidente avec
impatience et enthousiasme dans la
nièvre et pour ma part je piaffe qu'on
puisse se mettre au travail justement
sur les questions la ruralité qui est
pour nous nivernais un combat de longue
date nous avons beaucoup d'idées
nous avons fait beaucoup de choses aussi
avec la la région pendant ses plus de 10
années et nous l'attendons de pied ferme
au sens positif du terme
je pense qu'il y a aujourd'hui c'est
vrai dans le monde rural une réalité un
sentiment d'abandon mais qu'il ya des
solutions et des solutions concrètes et
c'est ce que nous voulons faire avec
marie guite et son équipe christian paul
bonjour est ce qu'on peut dire que
marie-guite dufay a été élu grâce à une
union de la gauche qui n'existe plus
statutairement et est-ce que de votre
point de vue il va falloir trouver des
solutions pour lui donner un
prolongement
mais vous avez raison nous avons besoin
de toute la gauche le parti socialiste a
besoin de toute la gauche et toute la
gauche a besoin du parti socialiste et
c'est à ce prix là que nous pouvons
espérer que dans les années qui viennent
même si on ne faut pas se projeter tout
de suite dans les élections futures
j'ai entendu beaucoup de choses tout à
l'heure qui relevait des débats
politiciens mais c'est vrai que nous
avons besoin de ressouder cette majorité
cette majorité de 2012 qui avait donné
beaucoup d'espoir aux français j'ai
entendu marie-guite dufay tout à l'heure
qui disait que l avait dans sa campagne
rencontrer le doute la déception et la
colère je ne me résigne pas à cette
déception est mon combat en ce moment
c'est justement de faire en sorte que ce
que nous allons faire au plan régional
avec cette nouvelle équipe ce que nous
pouvons faire au plan national s'il ya
justement une réorientation de la
politique nous avons besoin d'un nouvel
agenda politique pour la france et ça
doit commencer dès le début de l'année
on peut pas continuer comme s'il ne se
passait rien dans le pays vous savez
l'année 2016 c'était une année qui a été
marquée par les attentats bien sûr donc
un état de choc
un état d'urgence en matière de sécurité
mais il ya aussi un état d'urgence en
matière économique et sociale le chômage
de masse n'a pas reculé
et moi je crois à la convergence de
l'action locale ce que nous pouvons
faire à l'échelle de cette grande région
avec une présidente qui a une solide
expérience qui est très créative en
matière de lutte contre le chômage l'a
inventé ce que nous voulons faire au
plan national avec la sécurité sociale
professionnelle elle l'a expérimenté en
franche comté
donc je crois cette convergence entre
l'action régionale sur le terrain en
mobilisant les forces et les énergies
d'un pays qui n'a pas résidé qui n'a pas
résolu qui ne s'est pas résigné n'a pas
résolu d'être un un pays sans avenir
et puis une action nationale à laquelle
il faut sans doute donner davantage de
vigueur davantage de volonté politique
moi je souhaite au fond que que la
gauche qui est au pouvoir qui rendra des
comptes évidemment 2017 retrouve à la
fois ses idéaux et son efficacité
merci et christian paul en direct de
paris sur cette unité peut être michel
leniaud marie-guite dufay et la
candidate qui
réussir à réunir tous les personnalités
de ces personnalités du parti socialiste
déjà vous sais j'ai dit plusieurs fois
sur votre studio
la clé du succès pour la gauche a
toujours été l'unité du parti socialiste
c'est ce qui s'est fait de la
constitution des listes
le rassemblement le plus large possible
au premier tour
c'est ce que nous avons et c'est hier et
puis nous avons préparé aussi le
rassemblement du deuxième tour qui prend
une forme nouvelle comme l'a dit
marie-guite dufay qui est faux et
inventé quelque chose pour
qu'effectivement ce qui nous ont apporté
leur voix puisse avoir quelques veaux
chapitre pendant pendant les discussions
budgétaires mais vous suivez christian
paul qui pense que le gouvernement doit
aussi modifier sa politique son
positionnement regarder un peu plus vers
la gauche c'est pas forcément votre
ligne politique jusqu'à maintenant au
sein du ps initial audio non mais je
pense que ce qui est important c'est de
trouver des convergences et on sait bien
qu'après une élection il ya toujours des
enseignements à tirer
et effectivement si bon moment pour
changer de politique pour infléchir on
parle pas de changer de politique à un
an deux ennemis d'un scrutin c'est ce
que demande christian christian vient de
demander que la pole demande une
inflexion est d'avoir un mouvement
convergence si j'ai bien compris gestion
un mouvement convergent entre une
politique nationale et une politique
régionale pour mettre des forces en
chambre pour répondre à un sentiment
désespérance dont j'ai dit tout à
l'heure que c'était plus une impression
ressentie dans un certain nombre de cas
et nous avons des solutions apportées
pour cela et ça doit passer par le
dialogue territorial et se coupe une
réponse de christian paul convergence ce
sera suffisant christian tout en tout
cas dialogue territorial entre le
nouveau conseil régional et les
territoires de bourgogne franche comté
je le dis en particulier pour la nièvre
et vraiment je suis totalement
disponible pour qu'on se mettre au
travail dès cette semaine
j'espère que nous verrons très vite
marie-guite dufay l'équipe régionale
dans la dans la nièvre au plan au plan
national il faut se donner
le temps d'un inventaire d'un diagnostic
moi je n'ai pas la vérité révélée je
pense que chacun au sein du parti
socialiste à vous de cette vérité je
pense qu'il reste encore plus dumas mais
pour faire des choses utiles et qu'il ne
faut pas s'enfermer dans la routine du
pouvoir dans des certitudes tout fait je
pense que beaucoup de choses n'ont pas
encore été essayées et donc je plaide
c'est vrai je le ferai ce soir au bureau
national du parti socialiste pour que
l'on ne fasse pas la politique de
l'autruche que on n'est ce pas le pays
s'enfermer dans la peur après une année
qui a été dramatique et que de façon
très volontariste
on utilise tous les moyens disponibles
pour redonner aux français confiance
sécurité sécurité bien sûr face aux
menaces que l'on connaît mais la
sécurité au moins autant sur le plan
économique et social merci christian
paul ce sera le mot de la fin
dernier tour par les réseaux sociaux
elle avec un dernier tweet est un truc
qui peut résumer l'humeur du jour je
vous le montre c'est celui d'élise et
biecher une nouvelle conseillère
régionale socialiste en franche comté
qui écrit je je suis pas voilà je suis
sur le banc et 11 victoires un nouveau
mandat et un bon rhume bref vimont
lendemain électorale régions de gauche
certes mais région glacial merci à tous
de votre participation retrouvez toute
l'info sur les régionales sur les sites
de france 3 bourgogne et france 3
franche comté également bien sûr dans
votre 19/20 pour retrouver les résultats
au plus près de chez vous ou tout de
suite sur france 3 votre série 1 cas
pour deux très bel après midi